hello everyone and welcome to the 1909
match between josé raúl capablanca and
Frank Frank James Marshall we already
covered a few games for those of you who
are just tuning in to this series or
perhaps to this channel we are doing
some of the nicer and more important
games in the life of Jose raúl
capablanca the Cuban legend we already
covered a couple of his games against
the Cuban champion Juan Corso when he
was 13 years old now we are here in this
excellent match against we could say the
strongest player in the United States
after the death of the official champion
Harry Nilsson's
Harry Nilsson Pillsbury in 1906 and this
is game 8 kappa blanka is 3 points in
the lead and in vm7 Capablanca did lose
one game to Marshall but I'm saving that
game for the end of this match so we're
gonna skip that one but we are gonna
return to it as it will be a shame not
to show a nice game by Frank Marshall as
well as he is facing a legend here so
without further ado Capablanca has the
white pieces again he opens with E 4 and
again we're gonna have a very nice game
where a cup of Blanca just shows that
even though he has no knowledge of
opening Theory how he how easily but
just by using the principles he punishes
Marshalls play in the opening oh ok e4
e5 we have Knight to f3 sorry about that
Knights the c6 and Bishop to b5 guru
Lopez is on the board and d6 again we
have the old steinitz defense we have
castles by Capablanca a6 asking whether
the bishop will retreat or capture on c6
cup of lanka decides to capture the shot
captures pawn captures and now d4 I will
have pawn captures Knight captures
attacking the c6 pawn and the marshal
defends it with Bishop to d7 and rook to
e1 so you can see that capablanca
already Castle so his King is very safe
the rook is already active on e1 the
knight is a very strong in the center of
the board on d4 the Queen can car coming
to the play via h5 f 3e to the knight
can coming to the game so the
development of Capablanca species that
feels very natural where marshal he does
have a semi-open fall for his rook he
does have a pretty strong central
control but he still has a long way to
go to finish
development so how do you finish
development here this is the exact same
moment where we want to go Bishop e7
Knight f6 and then just castle but
Marshall goes c5 first first he kicks
the night away from this very nice
active square Knight to f3 and now
Bishop to e7 now Marshall wants the
complete development as well
Knight to c3 just a natural developing
move and here you want to develop
further but the problem with Knight to
f6 now is that now he five is is an
option as you've kicked away this night
from d4 to f3 then I support the support
c5 and after D captures Knight captures
now you can castle but you can see that
things are really are working in White's
favor Bishop to g5 you already
threatened to capture on f6 and then
there will be a double attack against
the bishop on d7 and after Bishop to e6
now you can go knight c6 attack the
Queen and the bishop after the Queen
moves Knight captures Queen captures and
now nice to e4 already you're attacking
the pinned piece and you can feel that a
wise position is just getting better and
better Queen d7 yo for Queen trade but
Knight captures on f6 with check G
captures Bishop captures and after black
exchanges Queens as he doesn't really
have anything better you can see that
the white is already up material he's up
upon and even even though they are
bishops of opposite course there are two
rooks on the board and in couple Blanca
sense this would be winning and you
can't even capture a pawn because there
are even threats of something like Rudy
three-room g3 checkmate so not that easy
to complete development now even though
it's very very early in the game so
Marshall tries a c6 takes control of the
d5 square he wants to play Bishop to e6
and then push d5 Bishop to f4 by playing
c6 now the d6 pawn becomes weak so the
Queen and the support now attacking yet
Bishop to e6 the Queen now joins in the
defense of the d6 pawn and now Queen d3
couple monka continuous development
Knight to f6 black now prepares the
castle but first rook a to d1 would a
triple attack against the d6 pawn and
here there is a no way to further defend
your porn so Marshall advances it we
have d5 and now not capturing but first
Bishop the
five and here you could take this moment
to Castle but if you Castle now then you
get a five and what are you gonna do
with this night you can't move it
because of Queen captures on h7
checkmate and if you play something like
94 and then simply night see characters
on e4 d captures Queen captures again
you're threatening checkmate and you're
also threatening to capture the Queen it
will be impossible to prevent both
threats you will have to capture with
the bishop on g5 give up the Queen for a
night and the rook and White will be
winning here so after this Knight to g5
move Catholicism is a premature here but
what could you do if you capture on e4
still doesn't work Queen g3 you open up
a discovery against the black Queen
after the Queen moves like the Queen see
it then comes Bishop to d6 again you're
not allowing black the castle because of
Bishop captures on e7 the bishop 27 is
unguarded and after Bishop captures
Queen captures now the black king is
never castling and with this rook being
stuck on h8 it's as if white is up a
full rook if you try something like rook
to a7 the keep an eye on the seventh
rank then comes Knight G captures on e4
there's really no good way to prevent
this Knight captures Knight captures and
now there are a lot of threats here you
can see that both fires of a her rooks
are excellently placed on open files and
here after something like roof to d7
Queen captures on c5 you're still
keeping an eye on this diagonal black is
never castling here let's say Queen c7
now comes Knight d6 check and here
you're just winning you have to give up
the exchange because well if you go King
f8 then you win the Queen straight up as
there's a very nice discovery the king
is in check and if you don't if you go
something like King here
all right then again you get rook
captures and e6f captures on e6 and now
Queen g5 check and again you don't
really have an option you have to go
rookie 7 and now Knight d5 check again
you force the King to go to d8 you win
the Queen so not a lot of ways to
prevent this after kappa blanka plays
Knight to g5 so black has already a lot
of difficulties Marshall tries to close
the position DeForest played here and
here we have Knight captures on e6 first
attacking the Queen you are forcing
black to capture on e6 pawn captures and
now comes Knight play for
this would have been perhaps a nice
opportunity for black to castle but
still it's not easy if you Castle Queen
c4 with a double attack against the the
c5 pawn also the e6 pawn is under attack
it would be a very uncomfortable
position for Marshall so after nine a
four we have Queen 285 Marshall first
attacks the rook here brings another
defender to the c5 pawn we have b3 kappa
blanka defends it and now comes Rock to
d8 and here we have nice to be two now
kappa blanka decides to transfer this
nice on c4 it's an excellent square for
the knight also it will save time as it
will come with an attack against the
black queen and here again if you try
castling you're getting Queen to h3 here
with a very very nice attack against the
e6 pawn you don't want to allow this
so first the Marshall tried knife to h5
perhaps if this bishop comes to g3 then
Queen to h3 will not be a possibility
but Capablanca plays Bishop to e5
instead and it's a very important move
already attacking the king said
pressuring the King side it controls the
d6 square which will be very important
in the future both d6 + f6 but allows
black the castle but it doesn't matter
now add like finally castle and 19th
move and he could have already started
castling instead of that c5 kicking out
the knight by already playing bushell 3
7 but ok he completed development
unmoved 19 but now capablanca has night
c4 the queen is under attack we have
Queen to b4 and now comes Queen to h3
with an attack against this stranded
Knight and h5 and also against the e6
pawn so you cannot prevent both threats
g6 is played defending the knight and
now Queen captures on e6 with check you
cannot move the King as the bishop
controls this diagonal you have to block
and also is the only move but it's you
know just as well as your better 27 is
under attack and here there are a couple
of ways capablanca can continue this but
he plays the most enjoyable move that is
g4 what do you do with with the dark
knight here you can't move it F F 4 and
F 6 are off-limits
the rook cannot help the defending as
the rook is pinned here so you could
play Knight g7 but then Bishop captures
you have to capture with the King and
five you're either losing the rook here
or if you move the rook then you lose
the bishop so you white is completely
winning here after this g4 move Marshall
tried Bishop to h4 he saw that it's
impossible to defend anymore now we have
to start an attack so there's the threat
against the f2 phone kappa blanka says
no problem G captures on h5 and now Bush
of captures an f2 with check King - h1
and now what do you do if you play
Bishop captures anyone it doesn't work H
captors and g 6h captures Queen captures
and now you're getting checkmate it if
you block with the rocket it's mating
one you have to try and run away but
then Knight b6 you're threatening
checkmate and after a few checks rook f1
check kingi taurua to check team g1
there are no more useful checks and
there is no good defense against Queen
g7 that will be checkmate you can try it
try to run away but today you get 95
check King D 7 Queen f7 check King moves
and Queen c7 will be checkmate but every
other line ends in checkmate so just as
well so after King - h1 black cannot
capture marshal plays Quintus e3 marshal
finds a very nice counter attacking idea
Queen c3 will a queen of three will be
checkmate as the bishop is covering g
covering g1 but here Capablanca has a
fantastic resource I want you to pause
the video here and try to find the move
Capablanca played it's really just a
very clever move so try to find a clever
move I'll give you a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations it's really
really a clever move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
rook to e3 excellent move as you can see
that the pawn cannot capture its pawn
captures its mate in one row captures
the bishop still controls this diagonal
the rook is pinned
if you don't capture with the point if
you capture with the bishop then the
bishop is blocking the Queen's approach
to the f3 Square and now you simply
continue our attack h5 % g 6h capture
screen captures with check and now it's
a similar idea like before either rook
blocks and then Queen captures is made
in 1 or you will run away with the King
King f8 but now Knight d6 attacks the
rook there's no look f1 check anymore
because the
controls f1 so you have to prevent it
and then after Knight captures rook
captures Bishop d6 check it will be over
very quickly King eh queen e6 check King
d8 now you can simply capture on f7
there's no defense it will be a
checkmate very soon
so as you cannot capture with the pawn
or with the bishop
you cannot capture the roof Marshall
plays Queen captures on c2 again he
prevents white from continuing the
attack H capture seer will be met with
racquel a queen captures rook on d1 so
first we have rook e to d3 getting the
rock out of harm's way and also
protecting the rooks here and now you
are also covering the f3 square so any
future Queen e2 perhaps you have three
ideas will not be possible as the rook
now is covering the f3 square
Queen - E - Marshall finds yet another
attacking Radia he wants to play Bishop
to e1 and finish off with Queen to f1
checkmate so how does capablanca go
about this Knight to d6 attacking the
pin piece of course the thread is made
in one Queen captures on f7 so there's
not much option here rook captures and
e6 was played you have to play this
Bishop captures and now bash up the e1
here Marshall threatens not that of
course but Queen to f1 checkmate and how
do you prevent this
well it's there's a really only one line
Queen to d8 check you have to block or
move or you don't want to block you'll
get Queen captures on f8 King g7 and
here I'm sure you all see it I will give
you a second to see it the move
Capablanca played as it's a very nice
move a couple of uncomplete h6 and it
was in this position on move 31 that
Frank James Marshall resigned the game
what if you resign well if you decide to
capture the pawn then of course you lose
the rook and there's no comfortably the
Queen from f7 is controlling f1 there is
no checkmate and after you play a check
here Queen captures on e4 you can block
with the rook and now any move you make
will of course and the game very quickly
Bishop fhx engage 5 you can go Queen
captures in h7 check and after you move
you can simply just trade everything and
you'll just be much better and of course
after h6 if you don't capture if you
decide
to defend the rook here then of course
again you will see it Queeny 5 this will
be checkmate as the rook on f7 and pawn
on g6 create a wall a barrier against
the black king so the black King cannot
escape anywhere and I also will use this
as a thumbnail as it's very nice so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
some of you mentioned in the comments
that I did mention there was some
controversy to this match but then I
didn't say anything about it I'm saving
that for the last game we'll be showing
in this match and then we're gonna
complete the entire story about this
match before we had off the couple
bunkers first international tournament
in San Sebastian of 1911 yeah I would
like to thank Alexander Chernobyl ski
nebbish America and the Talbot hunt
Slavic and Stefan McNeil's McNally's for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
videos but most likely continuing the
Capablanca saga and this match with
Frank James Marshall thank you all and
I'll see you soon